we do something on here where we do
something fun nice for single moms so we
had somebody who called in and submitted
one so let's get that video up real
quick
i just want to uh nominate my friend
krista
and her three little hellion kids for
the single moms
uh so when on my mother's day i just
want to nominate my friend katie
for the single moms i'd like to nominate
my sister ashley
i really appreciate what you do with the
single moms i want to nominate
my cousin jesse brown man i wanted to
nominate my best friend casey
i wanted to nominate my co-worker kim as
a single mother
hey kim yes i don't want to let you know
i'm not like a weirdo i'm not with the
government or anything
i was raised by a single mom so um yeah
every now and
then and then we just try and like give
back to the community so we just wanted
to give you a thousand bucks to go do
something fun with your kiddos
[Music]
yeah i'm totally serious
[Music]
god that is so nice well you're really
welcome
oh my god so that's it we just want to
let you know that people are thinking of
you
uh we hope you guys go do something fun
and and uh that's it you can just go on
about your day
thank you you bet like that a lot
you're welcome we just want to let you
know we out there grinding with you you
doing all the work but we got your back
that's all we say
you know hey you know and that's that's
right
thank you guys so much and it's who's
cheering back like you just said so
thank you so much
well we love you and you know i just
wish when i was young sometimes somebody
would have helped my mom out even just
something little you know
because i know it's really it's not hard
but it's just
i don't know sometimes we all want
people to just know that
we all want to know we're cared about a
little bit sometimes you know